thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
this is a story about clothing
it's about the clothes we wear
people who make these clothes and the
impact that it's having on our world
foreign
it's a story about greed and fear
power and poverty
it's complex as it extends all the way
around the world
but it's also simple
revealing just how connected we are to
the many hearts and hands behind our
clothes
[Music]
I came into the story with no background
in fashion at all
beginning with nothing more than a few
simple questions
what I've discovered has forever changed
the way I think about the things I wear
in My Hope
is that it might just do the same
for you
maybe just start and say your name and
talk about how this kind of began my
name is Lucy Siegel I am a journalist
and broadcaster based in the UK and I
have been obsessed consumed with the
environmental and social impacts of the
fashion industry for
well I love everything about clothes you
know I love I love the Poetry I love the
fabric I love the colors I love the
textures I love the way that they make
you feel you know they are our chosen
skin well I had the classic
massive closet clothes everywhere bags
constantly coming into my house you know
every day every other day with some
other item in and never had anything to
wear I could never put together a
coherent outfit
we communicate who we are to a certain
extent through clothing and this is this
is again throughout history you know you
have the Transit Court you know again
Mary Antoinette making this
it's always been it's our personal
Communication in many ways that's what
interests me that it is fundamentally a
part of what
um we wish to communicate about
ourselves
foreign
and we used to have a system a fashion
system where people would go to the
shows so they would do spring summer
autumn winter and those kind of ran like
clockwork for very many years okay rip
that up throw it out the window that has
absolutely nothing to do with the
fashion industry today it has been
reinvented the shift is moving
ruthlessly
um towards a way of producing which only
really looks after big business interest
growing up I never gave much thought to
anything other than the price of the
clothes that I bought usually making
choices based on style or a good deal
looking back I learned that for a long
time most of our clothing was actually
made right here in America
[Music]
as recently as the 1960s we were still
making 95 of our clothes
today we only make about three percent
and the other 97 percent is outsourced
to developing countries around the world
[Music]
I've been in the business for over nine
years now in terms of scale we got about
25 000 people just on government
manufacturing side we produce one in six
Threshers sold in the U.S
if you actually go to a store and you
Benchmark the price of a garment for
over the last 20 years you will find
that it's actually a deflationary
product I think the price has gone down
over time now has our costs gone down
absolutely not okay the cost has gone up
the more production we've outsourced the
cheaper prices have become on the
clothing we buy making a way for a whole
new model known as fast fashion almost
overnight transforming the way clothing
is bought and sold the newest h m store
on on Fifth Avenue in Manhattan is the
company's largest ever and just one of
many new stores it's planning around the
country it's all part of a High Street
Revolution fast fashion instead of two
seasons a year we practically have 52
Seasons a year so we have something new
coming in every week and fast fashion
has created this so that it can
essentially shift more product
[Music]
can get this Fringe metallic skirt for
39 at Joe Fresh a brand new store in
town with price tags that might look a
little bit more appealing to budget
conscious Shoppers American consumers
they really have grass the fashion part
of h m and we know from before that
American Zoom is a very value-oriented
if you match these two together with
fashion and value then you have a recipe
one Japanese clothing retailer is making
a Fast and Furious march here in the U.S
the price has dropped the way of making
that product has completely completely
changed and you have to ask yourself at
some point where does it end the global
Marketplace is some place where we
export work to have happen in whatever
conditions we want and then the products
come back to me cheap enough to throw
away without thinking about it
or globalized production basically means
that all of the making of goods has been
outsourced to low-cost economies
particularly where wages are very low
and kept low and what that means is that
those at the top of the value chain they
get to choose where the products are
being made and they get to switch if for
example one Factory says we can't make
it that cheap anymore the brand will say
well we're not going to come to you
anymore we're going to switch to another
place which is cheaper
foreign in the west they are using
everyday low price
so every day they're empireing me and
I'm hampering my workers this is how it
is they are competing the stores are
competing in there when the stores are
coming to us for order and negotiating
they're telling look that particular
store is selling this shirt with like
five dollars so I needed to sell it in
the four dollar
so you better squeeze your price so we
are squeezing then other store is coming
and selling hey they're selling it the
four dollar so the Target price is three
if you can make the three you are
getting business otherwise you are not
getting because we want that business so
badly and we don't have other options
okay every time we are trying to okay
survive actually
ultimately something's going to give
either the price of the product has to
go up
or manufacturers have to shut down or
cut Corners to make it work
cutting corners and disregarding safety
measures had become an accepted part of
doing business in this new model
until an early morning in April when an
event just outside of Dhaka Bangladesh
brought a hidden side of fashion to
front page news State media in
Bangladesh say an eight-story building
has collapsed near the capital of Dhaka
killing more than 70 people
[Music]
today
foreign
about
problems in the supply chain
particularly for fast fashion and try to
articulate how the risk was being
carried by those who are most vulnerable
and the worst paid
you try to articulate that but you could
never have envisaged that there would be
such a catastrophic illustration of what
you were trying to say and Rana Plaza to
me was like some Horror Story I think
one of the the most profoundly
impressing things about the roller Plaza
disaster was that news that the workers
had already pointed out to the
management the cracks in the building
they'd already pointed out that the
building was structurally unsafe and yet
they'd been forced back in many
survivors are asking how they could have
been forced to return to work when
management already was aware of the
cracks in the building and workers
concerns on the very day of the collapse
a lot of clothes in American stores are
made in Bangladesh by workers who earn
about two dollars a day last month there
a garment Factory collapsed killing more
than one thousand and a few months
before that a factory fire killed than
100 and his bodies are still being
pulled out of the rubble another Factory
in Bangladesh caught fire early this
morning killing eight more people
as story after Story of clothing Factory
disasters kept filling the news it was
now the case that three of the four
worst tragedies in the history of
fashion had all happened in the last
year as the death toll Rose so did the
prophets generated the year following
the disaster at Rana Plaza was the
industry's most profitable of all time
the global fashion industry is now an
almost 3 trillion dollar annual industry
Bangladesh is now the second largest
apparel exporter after China how well
unlike some of its competitors
Bangladeshi manufacturing remains dirt
cheap and unions have limited power the
country cornered the absolute bottom of
the value chain
those 1000 poor girls
lost their life because everybody didn't
bother didn't give damn [ __ ] and they
just wanted the cheap price and the good
profit it shouldn't be like that
everybody should take the responsibility
for those kids
that's how it is
and it might coming coming more sorry
but yeah you know that it's not only the
Press pressure it's something ignoring
other people's life is it's it's it's
not it should it's not right it's 21st
century
it's a global world we are living and we
just ignore other people's life
how come this enormous
rapacious industry that is generating so
much profit for a handful of people
why is it that it is unable to support
millions of its workers properly why is
it that it is not able to guarantee
their safety we're talking about
essential human rights why is it unable
to guarantee that whilst generating
these tremendous profits is it because
it doesn't work properly that is my
question
Lucy's question sounds like the obvious
one but instead of answering it
everywhere I looked I found people who
were constantly justifying the cost
because of the economic benefits being
generated
so this low-wage manufacturing or
so-called sweatshops they're not just
the least bad option workers have today
they're part of the very process that
raises living standards and leads to
higher wages and better working
conditions over time your proximate
causes of development are physical
capital technology and human capital are
skills of the workers when sweatshops
come to these countries they bring all
three of those to these workers and
start getting that process going is it
possible that sweatshops are actually
good yes horrible awful sweatshops the
word itself Sweatshop it evokes terrible
images of poor people and children
suffering in third world countries
slaving away in awful conditions to make
products for us selfish Americans and
thank you what does it does it bother me
that people are working in a factory
making clothes for
Americans or for you know Europeans or
that they're that's how they're spending
their lives
is that what you're kind of asking me um
um
no I mean you know they're doing a job
there are a lot worse things that they
can be doing it is live television and I
will ask you to find sweatshops yeah I
think we have to be very clear what
we're talking about from the outset so
we're talking about places with very
poor working conditions as us normal
Americans would experience at very low
wages by our standard maybe children
working places that might not obey local
labor laws but there's a key
characteristics of the type of ones I
want to talk to you about tonight
Kennedy and that's that they're places
where people choose to work admittedly
from a bad set of other options well I
mean there's nothing intrinsically
dangerous with sewing clothes so we're
kind of starting out with you know
a relatively safe industry it's not like
coal mining or
gas mining
so sweatshops jobs look like horrible
working conditions and wages to anybody
in the west who's wealthy enough to own
a TV and watch your video but we have to
keep in mind that the Alternatives
available for these workers aren't our
own Alternatives they're much worse than
our Alternatives and they're usually
much worse than the factory job that the
worker has
low wages unsafe conditions and Factory
disasters are all excused because of the
needed jobs they create for people with
no alternatives
this story has become the narrative used
to explain the way the fashion industry
now operates all over the world
but there are those who believe that
there must be a better way of making and
selling clothing that does generate
economic growth but without taking such
an enormous toll
so we don't know yet
um how long this embroidery is taking do
you think you could ask John to just
yeah just roughly how long that whole
panel is taking because I guess we'll
see it later on in the Fab press
breakdown but it would be great to know
wouldn't it so I'm satyamini I'm founder
and CEO of people tree and uh people
tree is a fair trade fashion brand that
started over 20 years ago in Japan
you're worried that we had a bit too
much Navy what are you feeling now
because we did put more black into ss14
and that has worked really really well
with um all of all his um designer
collaboration have we got enough black
Print in the collection uh well we've
lost that abstract but dust print this
one here in the black but I think this
pink could be really I think it's one of
those prints that everyone's a bit
nervous of but actually will do well
I think most fashion brands start with a
concept of a collection or a look
um they don't tend to think uh you know
who is going to make the product and how
can I ensure that
producers or suppliers are going to eat
um so what we're trying to do people
tree is really start with uh the skills
that we have at each producer group and
then design The Collection up whilst
also looking at the Integrity of the
collection in its aesthetic
I worked originally with freelance
designers and went into Bangladesh
Zimbabwe India Nepal the Philippines and
bit by bit we put together you know an
amazing network of like-minded fair
trade organizations that put women's
development the workers Social
Development and environment absolutely
essential to everything they do
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
that's beautiful fair trade is a
citizen's response to correcting the
social injustice in a international
trading system that is largely
dysfunctional where uh workers and
farmers are not paid
um a living wage and where the
environment is is not considered at all
to make the products that we buy every
day
thank you
dishwasher I mean
[Music]
Shima is one of about 40 million garment
Factory workers in the world
almost 4 million of these workers are
here in Bangladesh working in almost 5
000 factories making clothing for major
Western brands
over 85 percent of these workers are
women and with a minimum wage of less
than three dollars a day they are among
the lowest paid garment workers in the
world
[Music]
foreign
not yet
[Music]
I wondered
foreign
must not have any kind of distrust on
their owns
if they have
their lord be any good working
atmosphere in the factory
they must respect the owner is paying us
as per rule
if they do not have this kind of
confidence you won't get the result
um
foreign
foreign
it's estimated that one in every six
people alive in the world today work in
some part of the global fashion industry
making it the most labor dependent
industry on Earth most of this work is
done by people like Shima who have no
voice in the larger supply chain
but to fully understand the impact the
fashion is having on our world we have
to go back to where it all begins
parents settled out here in the 20s and
so this is a part of my Heritage people
ask why I'm an organic cotton farmer
it's because I don't know any better my
granddaddy was an old German farmer that
felt like we should respect the land
we're stewards of the land and we expect
the life that's in the land
you're actually sitting in the high
plains of Texas and there's 3.6 million
Acres of cotton grown in this region
we're literally the biggest Cotton Patch
in the world in just the past 10 years
80 percent of that is now GMO
genetically modified cotton most of it
is Roundup Ready meaning that instead of
the farmer's spot spraying weeds
occasionally in their field or hiring
laborers to walk the field and eliminate
the Weeds now they're spraying whole
fields
cotton produces the fiber that's
responsible for most of the clothing
worn by the world today and as our
appetite for fashion grows the cotton
plant itself is being re-engineered to
keep up there's been this big drive
towards the industrialization of
Agriculture the intensification of
Agriculture so instead of the old forms
of farming which were very much in tune
with nature they were they were linked
to the cycles of the natural year and
the seasons what you see now is an
intensification where the land is almost
reconsidered as if it was a factory
what you've created is this general
practice of we treat millions of Acres
the same we put a dose of chemical on it
all
and that's when you get these big
ecological effects that nobody has a
grasp of what's really happening
nature tends to heal itself in small
pockets
but when you get this big broad approach
we really don't know what's going on for
us
it's not reducing the amount of
pesticides and chemicals that are going
on the Cotton that's one of the big
cells it reduces that not in our area
where we are spraying millions and
millions of acres and dollars of Roundup
across the entire South Plains what kind
of impact is that having on our soil
with residual
residuals that are left at the micro
bacterial level what kind of impact is
that having on the people in our
communities where's the cost on that
Monsanto is proud to be the industry
leader in agricultural Innovation
because of what these agricultural
advancements can do to help you double
yields for the future needs of the world
we're dedicated to the future of
Agriculture and providing Farmers with
innovations that help them produce more
and conserve more
while improving the lives of people
around the world
together we can face the challenges of
the Next Generation
and Beyond
[Music]
after the wars where all these redundant
factories that made more chemicals
explosives
were lying around
the Western countries thought that it
would be a good idea to Market them to
the third world after all the same
industry that makes explosives makes
nitrogen fertilizers
and they started to push nitrogen
fertilizers
from the 50s onwards after we became
independent but the
nitrogen fertilizers don't do very well
with Native crops is a problem of
lodging
so the whole system then organized
itself to redesign the plant in order to
take on more chemicals BT cotton is a
cotton in which a gene has been added
from a bacteria to produce a toxin
but the beety cotton
supposed to control a pest
has been offered
because it's a way for companies to own
the seed
by patenting these genetically modified
plants Monsanto has become the largest
seed in Chemical Corporation in history
I wanted to speak with someone who had
worked with the company and I got word
that a former managing director for
India was willing to talk one of my
close friends who was in the research
situation working on this modified crops
he came to my hotel for a drink
you're sitting having a drink and after
a few drinks he told me hey Jack
you're going to change the type of
business you're doing in India
I said what do you mean
we are going to get into seeds business
and we are going to make the seed
business on all crops
so that we are the Monopoly and seeds
and every farmer has come to us to buy
seeds every time
that rang a bell in my mind
if a poor Farmers to go to Monsanto to
buy seeds every time
and such expensive seats
at the time there's no idea of BT at all
for Me Gently motivates it but it's not
in my mind
even seed Monopoly is something really
bad
so farmers get into debt when they get
the seed because of the high cost
seventeen thousand percent more
they get into deeper debt because it
doesn't deliver on the promise of
controlling pests so they have to buy
more pesticides the tragedy with
chemicals whether it's fertilizers or
pesticides is that they are what has
been called ecological narcotics the
more you use them the more you need to
use them for a while the yield of the
single commodity climbs and then it
starts to decline because you have
contaminated
the soil
most of India's cotton is grown in the
Punjab region which has quickly become
the largest user of pesticides in India
Dr prit Paul Singh has been studying the
effects of these chemicals on human
health and his reports show a dramatic
rise in the number of birth defects
cancers and mental illness here in the
region
you can go in every village you will see
that hundreds of patients are suffering
with the cancers 72 80 kids in every
village will find the mentors facing the
recipient and physical handicaption
foreign
[Music]
kids like this this war so it will be
very dangerous phenomena uh in in the
Punjab
and pupils farmers and labor there is a
small farmers and a labor maximum
Deliverance so they can't afford now
treatment ultimately they have accept to
the death of their kids
and they are waiting the death of their
kids mother is waiting for the death of
this boy
companies that make this GM seeds and
make the chemicals are the same
companies and they're also the same
companies that make the medicines which
they are not patenting so you get cancer
there are more profits for them it's a
win-win-win-win-win as for nature and
people it's a lose lose
it's the day those agents of these
companies come to the farmer and say
you owe me this much you haven't paid
back now your land is my land
that day the farmer will go into his
field
drink a bottle of pesticide and end this
life and every Widow I've talked to said
and the neighbors came and said they
first found my husband lying in the
field
in the last 16 years there have been
more than 250 000 recorded farmer
suicides in India
that's about one farmer every 30 minutes
and it's the largest recorded wave of
suicides in history
[Music]
as it becomes clear just how much of an
impact fashion is having on our world
there is an increasing amount of
research to suggest that it's also
having a growing effect on us the people
buying these clothes
what we now know 20 years later in
hundreds of studies later is that the
more that people are focused on those
materialistic values the more that they
say that money and image and status and
possessions are important to them the
less happy they are the more depressed
they are the more anxious they are we
know that all of these kinds of
psychological problems tend to go up as
materialistic values go up now that's
really at odds with the thousands of
messages that we receive every day from
advertisements suggesting that
materialism and the pursuit of
possessions and owning stuff is what's
going to make us happy it's important to
understand that advertising is a species
or a category of propaganda
we think of propaganda as a totalitarian
thing very Grim loudspeakers you know
chanting crowds and so on we think of
Hitler we always think of of it as a
foreign thing okay but it's actually as
American as apple pie
well the reason that advertising works
is because the smart advertisers at
least are trying to tie the consumption
of their product to a message that
suggests that your needs will be
satisfied by consuming this thing it
wants you to believe that you'll look
wonderful in that thing but then to put
it on and feel like that you look kind
of fat in it you don't look that good in
it you're sorry you bought it but
there's another one you can buy
the next Sky I'll be a God in the next
life
[Music]
so think of all of the car commercials
you see that show well I've really made
it now I'm a competent person because
I'm driving this BMW or this Audi or
think of all the shampoo commercials
you've seen where the person now has
beautiful flowing hair and is loved and
appreciated by the people around them
the basic message is the same the way to
solve the problems of your life we all
have problems in our life the way to
solve the problem in your life is
through consumption hey you guys today
I'm coming to you guys with a clothing
haul I went shopping a couple days ago
and literally went insane and bought so
many things my spam box I don't know
where is literally blown up by you guys
saying you guys wanted a haul so here it
is okey-dokey so first off I have some
things that I got from h m so then I
went to forever 21. it wasn't even a
question it was just like fate I just
had to get it like if it could levitate
towards me it would have levitated I got
this skirt
bright yellow and it was
8.50 it's a gene button-up thing and I
just love this I just loved it loved it
loved it it's a gray knit sweater and it
has pink hearts all over it I lived I
loved highlight things like tie-dye
things are literally the bomb.net it has
a little yin yang sign on the front of
it I just love these so much and it's
just this really pretty light blue
sweater I don't even know if I'm gonna
wear this now that I got it because I
don't know if I like it that much I need
to stop
I try to understand better why people
doesn't realize that they are becoming
poorer and poorer and I ask myself okay
but what has changed in spite of when I
was young and fashion is something that
has dramatically changed I was able to
buy one two T-shirts four t-shirt for
example a year now I mean also my my
children they used to buy every every
party I mean they buy a T-shirt and so I
understood that the fast fashion is
something totally new if you have
noticed the price has decreased in the
last years and it does follow
the middle class disappearing so all the
things that people really need
are very costs are very costly like home
like study like life insurance on the
other side there is a source of
consolation
um part of their life that I can
buy a t-shirt two T-shirts a party or
eventually a day
although I'm very poor and I've got lost
I've lost all the things I really needed
today we purchased over 80 billion
pieces of new clothing each year that's
400 percent more than the amount we
bought just two decades ago the way we
buy clothes has changed so much so fast
that few people have actually stepped
back to understand the origin of this
new model or the consequence of such an
unprecedented increase in consumption
there is um
an article in Printers Inc which is the
leading advertising trade Journal of of
its Day by a very famous copywriter
named Ernest Elmo Calkins Grand Old Man
of the art of writing advertising copy
it was an article called consumptionism
in that article he says there are there
are two kinds of products
okay they're the kind that you use like
washing machines cars and so on things
that you buy and use for a long time
and then there are the things that you
use up
like chewing gum in cigarettes other
perishables
he said consumptionism is all about
getting people to treat the things they
use
as the things they use up
with their Innovative buy one
free pricing a
lot they come in an easy to use
dispensers
with poor suits for the price of a
modest dinner I can good about throwing
them away when I'm done
you just have to look at landfill and
you can see in landfill that the amount
of clothes and textiles being chucked
away has been increasing steadily over
the last 10 years as the sort of dirty
shadow of the fast fashion industry
as we get sort of closer and closer to
see degradation to
trashing our last remaining pristine
Wilderness we seem hell-bent on
producing more and more disposable stuff
it makes no sense fashion should never
and can never be thought of as a
disposable product I think after any big
change in any industry it takes a while
to sort of
feel and smell the dirt that comes out
of something that is that is polluting
so I think now there is a change because
can't deny
that the fast fashion industry is having
a massive impact in developing countries
the average American throws away 82
pounds of textile waste each year adding
up to more than 11 million tons of
textile waste from the U.S alone most of
this waste is non-biodegradable meaning
it sits in landfills for 200 years or
more while releasing harmful gases into
the air
the sheer amount of cheap clothing even
though people feel perhaps somehow
that they're offsetting by giving to
charity you know the Journey of a
t-shirt donated to charity is
unpalatable in itself
[Music]
um it is a disease in Haiti not only in
Haiti I think I can earn any Eternal
world country that you're visiting like
you know it's a problem it's a huge
problem
Pepe a bunch of clothes most of them
came from the states
people will go and buy a box full of
clothes they don't even know what
they're buying
those are clothes people donate to
charity and charity cannot sell them on
their thrift store or whatever they pack
them ship them to those Third Country
and most of them end up here turns out
that only about 10 percent of the
clothes that we donate actually get sold
in local thrift stores
and as we're going through our clothing
faster and faster now more of it is
being dumped into developing countries
like Haiti
as the amount of secondhand clothing
coming into Haiti has increased the
local clothing industry here has
disappeared
once a proud local tailoring sector
Haiti now produces mostly cheap t-shirts
for export to America
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
people stop buying things that is not
good that is constantly like you know
ten dollars you're going to go on a on a
ball you're going out today you just go
to a store and buy yourself a dress for
ten dollars because I cannot it costs
ten dollars I don't need to throw it
away
and tomorrow you're going to do the same
thing over and over and over again
as awareness of Fashion's impact on our
world is growing there are key leaders
in the industry who are beginning to
question the impacts of a model built on
careless production and endless
consumption and Patagonia we hate the
word
consumers
it's we've got to find a better word we
prefer customers and we prefer also
customers who recognize the impact of
their consumption they recognize that as
consumers they're part of the problem we
are hopeful that we can encourage our
customers to join us in in really
questioning consumption because without
a reduction in consumption we don't feel
that we'll really collectively find a
solution to the problems we face that
are collectively
year by year resulting in the continued
decline of the health of our planet
I mean the fashion industry just needs
to think it needs to just stop and sort
of look at how it's been working in a
conventional way and just sort of
question it challenge it you know and
that's for me as a designer that's the
most exciting thing that I do now more
exciting than saying oh I love this
color this season or this is the
silhouette or the hemline for me way a
way bigger challenge in excitement is
actually looking at my industry and
saying you know what I'm going to try
and do in a way that is not as harmful
to the planet
business through advertising has uh has
pulled Society along into this belief
that happiness is based on stuff that uh
true happiness can only be achieved with
uh you know an annual
seasonal weekly daily increasing the
amount of stuff you're bringing into
your life that that we want to encourage
our customers to to think twice about
those assumptions to understand where
they came from and through that
understanding to know that we can all
together we can change how this is done
the customer has to know that they're in
charge without them we don't have jobs
you know and that is really important so
you don't have to buy into it if you
don't like it you don't have to buy into
it
thank you
[Music]
I love the embroidery shanty
should have the embroidery on both sides
I think we should definitely add the
embroidery here as well
I think it looks a bit mean to have it
just on the front so let's have it on
the sides too
it won't add much cost it's not so dense
is it
swallows is a fair trade fashion
business but it's also a development
Society so it helps more than 3 000
people in this Village
I come here every four months and we
call them production trips and um and
we're working with the producers trying
to find out you know what are the
barriers to making a great product and
to to getting it to the market and we're
also doing fair trade capacity buildings
so looking at you know what what are the
obstacles to delivering more social
benefit or improving you know the
Environmental Protection in the in these
areas for me this this is about
partnering this is about finding
Creative Solutions together with them
with the team here and really listening
to what their problems are and finding a
way that works together
foreign
the best employee
here at swallows I want to invite one
women one female representative from
swallows to come to London in Autumn or
next spring
and I would like you to think who would
be that best representative
but I want you to know who your
customers are and I want you to really
understand the marketplace and come back
and tell all your friends
foreign
[Applause]
people
[Music]
so um if she continues for a bit we're
gonna go to the song room now for ss15
yeah can she come and show us the next
one that she does yeah
I kind of hoped that people she wouldn't
be necessary and I hoped that
you know we would have a trading system
that looked after people's rights and
the environments and
but they're more and more involved they
got in developing and working closely
with Partners the more
you know dirt and filth I discovered
about how trading practices you know
undermine everything that we believe in
and everything I know most people
believe that value
um
I don't know people too just really grew
organically it grew from a really great
collection of people that feel
passionately that there's a different
way of of working of living of consuming
of you know interacting with people in a
humane way
and uh you know I mean I I didn't
necessarily feel that there'd be a
thousand shops selling people tree today
um
and I see there's so much more that we
need to do so I think it's not just
about you know creating jobs for 7 000
people that work for People Trees also
about being a catalyst for change you
know within the industry and showing
proving the model works
yeah when we were first been organic I
think there's only two or three of us at
the time we formed the Texas organic
cotton marketing cooperative
and the deal was they'd grow it and I'd
sell it so started going to like Jacob
Javits and having this whole deal cotton
plants and everything and of yeah we've
got organic cotton and people would just
look at us like we were absolutely crazy
many times consumers become aware of
organic milk or they have an allergy and
so interestingly enough cotton and what
they put on their body even though the
Skin's the largest organ on your body
isn't even on their radar screen because
they're not getting the connection of oh
I ate this Organic Apple therefore I'm
not directly ingesting pesticides or
chemicals or whatever the case may be
but they don't get that direct
connection with clothing and so you have
to start looking that in that bigger
Community scope that it is about our air
it's about our world it's about our
planet it's about our people
and so it is that awareness of you may
not feel that you're having the direct
impact by buying this organic shirt
but the impact you're having is in the
bigger picture in the World At Large and
especially in the community where the
Cotton's grown
as the hard freeze comes as organic
farmers we wait for that freeze because
that literally defoliates uh takes the
leaves off the plant
so that when we Harvest where the bowls
open that are mature
and it leaves the cotton here and you
can see it kind of comes out in sections
so this machine that's coming is called
the cotton stripper and it's called a
cotton stripper because it literally
comes along and strips uh use kind of
fingers and it literally strips all of
the bowls off of this this plant
so when you look over there you can see
the office has been there and it's taken
all the plants off
I think one of the problems that we have
in the current model is it's all about
the profit
and it doesn't take into consideration
at this cost at what cost the cost of
polluting the water the cost of Labor
the cost of bars on the window that
people die when a fire breaks out in the
factory the cost of farmers that don't
have access to education and health care
and so we haven't really factored in
what the true cost is
kanpur is situated a long river Ganga
which is the holiest River
and it's also very important for 800
million Hindus and also it serves as
Lifeline of North India so this river is
being polluted and killed by the leather
factories of kanpur
with growing demand for materials like
cheap leather compor is now the leather
export capital of India
every day here more than 50 million
liters of toxic Wastewater pour out of
the local tanneries heavy chemicals used
to treat the leather like chromium-6
flow into local farming and even
drinking water
in places like compor far from the eyes
of the world major Western brands are
able to Source cheap materials while
avoiding all accountability for the
growing cost to human health and the
environment
[Music]
people in that area
are in the tight grip of tan repollution
the local environment is contaminated
soil is contaminated the only drinking
water source groundwater is contaminated
with chromium
agricultural produce even vegetables and
salad items are produced there peoples
Health are affected people have
different kinds of dermal problems
the skin rashes boils specials even
numbness in the limbs people have this
stomach ailments maybe they have cancers
also
joined this is
foreign
[Music]
you can have the best of materials
moving into the high-end fashion Market
in Milan or Paris or London but there
have been so much of work which has gone
behind it and so much of chemicals has
gone into it the affluence have been
discharged into so many rivers but we
are only looking at that point of time
into the finished product
we need to step back and think about it
fashion today is the number two most
polluting industry on Earth second only
to the oil industry
the alarming thing is that not only is
fashion using a huge amount of natural
resources and creating staggering
environmental impacts these natural
resources and this impact is often not
even measured because they've been so
abundant these resources
it's been assumed that they're going to
be there forever
so I think business is not accounted for
them because
it's only since the 1950s that we've
really had this industrial
expansion at such a rate that we started
to see exponential growth and
exponential use of Natural Resources
the first economy on which allies rest
is Nature's economy Nature has an
economy
that economy is huge it's not counted
then we have people's economy women
working Weavers working Farmers growing
and that was made invisible through this
construct first in the depression and
then during the War years of the number
called the GDP the gross domestic
product which measures only that
which is traded and has become a
commodity
a lot of the resources that we use to
make our clothing are not accounted for
in the the cost of producing those
growths so when it has water that's used
to produce clothing land that's used to
grow the fiber
chemicals that are used to to die those
things all are inputs and as inputs they
cost something
and they also give outputs in some cases
good outputs the clothing themselves
jobs but in other cases bad outputs like
harmful chemicals or greenhouse gas
emissions and those things have costs as
well
I'm a relationship
s
anything with us
again
the same low wages that have made places
like Bangladesh so attractive for Brands
to do business
have left millions of workers here
working incredibly long hours unable to
afford to keep their children with them
even in the city's worst slums
in order to give their children an
education and the chance of a better
future than life in the factories many
garment workers here like Shima are
leaving their children to be raised by
family or friends in villages outside
the city only getting to see them once
or twice a year
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
no no
no
no
oh yeah
[Music]
this is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
need to work to use them as slaves and
I'm not saying that we don't you know we
need to give them work but it has they
have to be treated with the same respect
that we treat our children our friends
they're not different from us
Olivia Firth has been calling for major
change in the fashion industry
she made Headlines by starting something
called The Green carpet challenge
urging celebrities and top designers to
take part in more mindful forms of
fashion she runs the sustainability
consulting firm called Eco age and had
just been invited to speak at a
conference on the future of fashion if
fast fashion didn't exist
we wouldn't need to have some amazing
copenhage and hate to try and clean the
mess of environmental destruction social
justice destruction
that it has been caused in the last 15
to 20 years of his existence fast
fashion wants to produce fast so the
Garment worker has to produce faster
and cheap so the Garment worker is the
only point of the supply chain with the
margin has squeezed
and you have this huge you know
companies going to the factory in
Bangladesh place an order for 1.5
million genes for you know 30 cents each
50 cents each how can you make it
ethical I don't know
but also from the consumer point of view
is it really Democratic to buy a t-shirt
for five dollars a pair of jeans for
twenty dollars
or are they taking us for a ride
because they're making us believe that
we are rich or wealthy because we can
buy a lot
but in fact they're making us poorer and
the only person who is becoming richer
is the owner of the fast fashion branch
so that makes me a little bit angry
you spoke about a commitment to
try and and promise a basic living wage
what does that mean how do you define a
fair living wage in Bangladesh
you know
um
what does that mean and I have a pilot
project in three factories and by 2018
15 of your factories are gonna have that
it's not good enough it's not
it's very clear for us that what a
living wage is is something that the
workers should say and that's
Incorporated that's Incorporated in our
way of working and that's not for us to
say some but we do an assessment all the
time to make sure that it covers the
basic needs of the workers so it's I can
show you that later on h m has mastered
the model of fast fashion becoming the
second largest clothing Corporation in
history with annual revenue of more than
18 billion dollars
they are now one of the largest
producers of clothing in both Bangladesh
and Cambodia
sadly along with every other major
retailer I asked they declined all
interview requests for this film
[Music]
in Cambodia garment workers have had
enough
recently taken to the streets to demand
a minimum wage increase in the country
[Music]
as protests continued workers were met
with violent crackdowns as police began
to open fire with live grounds
[Music]
a woman has been killed and several
people injured in clashes between
clothes Factory workers and Riot police
in Cambodia
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the police the paratroopers were brought
in as if there were war on the street of
Plumbing why because workers in the
textile industry continue to demand a
minimum wage of at least 160 dollars
foreign
foreign
today is the funeral
of a factory worker he was beaten to
death he had suffered a lot before his
death this morning
and he
had done nothing wrong he among his
fellow workers
wanted to have a better living
conditions
but we have time
[Music]
[Music]
we will continue his fight
so that all
Cambodian workers
the Cambodian government like other
developing countries are desperate for
the business that multinational
retailers bring
because of the constant threat that
these Brands will relocate production to
other low-cost countries the government
holds down wages routinely avoiding
enforcement of local labor laws
but because the major brands do not
officially employ the workers or own any
of the factories they produce in they
are able to profit hugely all while
remaining free of responsibility for the
effects of poverty wages Factory
disasters and the ongoing violent
treatment of workers the whole system
begins to feel like a perfectly
engineered nightmare for the workers
trapped inside of it
you cannot fool us and exploit our human
resources exploit our workers the
workers will continue to rise up
I called on the international brands
to put that struggle into
dollars into pounds into Euros
it translates into human capital it
translates into social responsibility or
these big corporations it translates
into economic Justice
when everything is concentrated on
making profits for the big corporations
what you see is that human rights the
environment workers rights get lost
altogether you see that workers are
increasingly exploited because the price
of everything is pushed down and down
and down just to satisfy the this
impulse to accumulate capital and that's
profoundly problematic because it leads
to the mass impoverishment of hundreds
of millions of people around the world
if you write to any of these companies
they'll send you their code of conduct
and it's beautiful and it says oh yes we
take responsibility for the conditions
under which our product is made you know
the product that you buy all the
factories where we produce we require
them to respect the minimum wage laws
you know all of the laws of the country
to respect women not to hire children
no forced labor
no excessive overtime hours all that
stuff
um but when we submitted a Bill in
Congress a few years ago or worked with
worked with people to do that we called
it the the decent working conditions and
Fair competition act the companies
responded in one voice oh no that would
be an impediment to free trade we can't
we can't have rules we can't have we
can't have that they want to keep it
with voluntary codes of conduct now that
you know they've fought for and they've
won laws to protect their stuff and
their interests but you know what about
the workers the workers are left with
voluntary codes of conduct and what we
see in case after case after case is
that those voluntary codes of conduct
are not worth the paper that they're
written on we need to acknowledge
particularly in the fashion industry
that human capital is part of this
miraculous formula
without human capital without cheap
labor cheap female labor it would not be
generating the profits that it is
that needs to be acknowledged it needs
to be dealt with and those people need
to be rewarded instead of exploited
where is their piece of the pie that's
what we constantly have to ask ourselves
are those buyers immoral or do they just
don't are they a moral the system
they're working for the system that
allows companies to do this is amoral
the individual is concerned are simply
products in that system and having to
drive it through to its logical
conclusion what we need to do is change
the way those companies operate
operating within a system that only
measures profit companies have little
incentive to do anything other than to
make this quarter better than the last
no matter what damage is caused along
the way
as corporations that make up the global
fashion industry Major Brands as well as
seed and chemical companies are growing
today to reach unprecedented Global size
and power this mandate for profit at all
cost is beginning to stand in direct
opposition to the values that we share
Richard Wolff is an economist who after
graduating from Harvard Stanford and
Yale became convinced that the real
problem is within this system itself so
America became a peculiar country you
could criticize the education system to
make the schools better you could
criticize the transportation system to
make that work better you could quit put
but you couldn't criticize the economic
system that got a free pass
you couldn't criticize just you know and
if you don't criticize something for 50
years it rocks it goes to seed but one
of the ways a healthy Society works is a
subjects it's component systems to
criticism so that we can debate it and
hopefully fix it or improve it or do
better capitalism couldn't be questioned
capitalism is the reason the fashion
industry looks as it does today it's the
reason why workers in Bangladesh are
paid so little because if you're
operating in a capitalist system the
main thing you have to do is create
profit and you have to create more
profit than your competitors and this is
what drives companies to push wages down
and down and down like they don't cut
like companies don't go like fashion
retailers don't go to places like
Bangladesh for any other reason except
they can get the cheapest labor possible
like there's no Collective rights in
regulations no Trade union rights
there's a very very low minimum wage
there's no like maternity benefits
there's no pensions that is why the
fashion industry is in Bangladesh
because it can reap the biggest profits
out of those people that are that are
making the clothes for them before you
can solve a problem you have to admit
you've got one and before we're going to
fix an economic system that's working
this way and producing such tension and
inequalities and strains on our
community we have to face the real scope
of the problem we have and that's with
the system as a whole and at the very
least we have to open up a national
debate about it and at the most I think
we have to think long and hard about
alternative systems that might work
better for the environment the great
threat is that Capital must continue to
expand infinitely in order to survive it
can't have any limits on its expansion
and its growth the natural world clearly
does have limits there are very defined
limits to how much the world can sustain
in terms of production in terms of trade
in terms of transport and distribution
and it's quite clear that we've already
overstepped a lot of those limits which
is why you're seeing such stress in the
natural world at the moment
the system we live in isn't one that
most people want to live in I think it's
a system that makes most people very
unhappy and I don't think people want to
live on a slowly dying planet or to be
exploiting
um you know their neighbors so I think I
think we need huge systemic change if
you don't change this system you're
leaving intact the decision making of
these Enterprises which means a small
group of Executives and shareholders are
going to be working in the same system
subject to the same pattern of rewards
and punishments which will sooner or
later make them re-impose their or
elsewhere the very conditions you're
fighting against so stop this stuff
about improving their conditions deal
with their system or else you're not
serious our economic system is one of
consumer capitalism and that's why the
government needs to have consumption at
very high levels and why of course the
corporations do and why at some level
most people then buy into it you know I
can't tell you the number of people I
talk to who say well
but if we became less materialistic our
economy would tank well they're right in
some level because our economy is based
on
materialism it's based on these kinds of
values that's what it needs in order to
survive that's part of the fuel that it
needs
the problem is that comes at a really
high price
shopping Manny is still playing out
tonight at malls Across America in some
places across this country tonight it's
as if someone announced were in danger
of running out of stuff and those who
need stuff had better go out and buy it
now because it's going away forever
Walmart doing more than 10 million
transactions in the first four hours of
the frenzy a record 15 000 people at
Macy's in New York City Shoppers hung
tough Black Friday will be the single
largest day of the retail year certainly
in the case of Macy's we'll do more
business on this day than on any other
day of the year Nation this orgy of
Christmas shopping proves America is
back we are once again yes
oh yes
yes we are once again spending money we
don't have on things we don't need to
give to people we don't like
yeah
USA USA USA
[Music]
[Music]
I won't let anyone get in my way
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
guy that grew up on a farm
and those of us living on the farm and
play you know live there it needs to be
safe for us too and and the new
chemicals that are coming out and the
intensity of the use was just continuing
to increase and
um
and then in 2005
Terry started having some loss of fine
motor skills and this and that and come
to find out he had a glioblastoma
multiformi stage forward brain tumor
and at the prime age of 47 years old and
he died at the age of 50. they gave us
six months we had two and a half years
and the brain surgeon that worked on him
we've you know Lubbock has got a huge
cancer clinics and a hub medical Hub we
didn't have to go someplace else to have
a brain tumor surgery we were able to
stay right here because he does so many
of them he said that these kind of
tumors are found in men aged 45 to 65
that work in the agricultural industry
or the oil field
and so while I don't have a Smoking Gun
and the blood tests that say the use of
cotton chemicals and agricultural
chemicals directly led to my husband's
death
there's just too many linkages with his
father's death
growing up on a chemically intensive
Farm we live in the middle of 3.6
million Acres of cotton that use a lot
of chemicals and so at that point in
time
organic is was no longer important to me
it was imperative
it's imperative that we change
agriculture it's imperative if we're
talking about the long-term
sustainability and well-being of Our
Lives on this planet and our children's
lives on the planet that we have to
change
thank you
very much
this is the beginning of a turning point
not just for you know a responsible way
of doing fashion but for a new way of
doing capitalism for a new way of doing
economics
I'm I'm sure that we
we will see a significant change over
the next 10 years
um whether it's in time or not as
another question
if you know Martin Luther King Jr had a
speech in a Brooklyn church he said that
what what America needed was a
revolution of values it needed to stop
treating people like things needed to
stop treating people in ways that were
just about profit but instead to treat
people in a real and human way
my God we can do better than this if if
what we want is to spread as I would
argue we do spread industry around the
world not concentrated in one place let
it let the benefits be shared
globally then let's do that in an
orderly reasonable careful way we need
to recognize that capital is just money
money is a means
and people should be accountable for how
it's used
we need to celebrate the creative power
of human beings and we need to talk of
creative work we must stop talking about
Labor
we need to look at the
land as not a commodity
to be speculated on and traded but as
the very basis of our life as Mother
Earth
if you change your consumers into
activists
all consumers asking ethical questions
all consumers asking quite simple
questions about where their clothes are
from all consumers saying I'm sorry it's
not acceptable for someone to die in the
course of a working day we can't just
roll over and say yes have it do what
you like it's too important it's too
significant in Industry it has too much
impact and effect on millions of people
worldwide and common resources
[Music]
well we continue to search for happiness
and the consumption of things
will we be satisfied with a system that
makes us feel rich while leaving our
world so desperately poor
will we continue to turn a blind eye to
the lives of those behind our clothes
or will this be a turning point a new
chapter in our story when together we
begin to make a real change as we
remember that everything we wear was
touched by human hands
in the midst of all the challenges
facing us today
for all the problems that feel bigger
than us and beyond our control
maybe we could start here
with clothing
[Music]
[Music]
on the other side
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when I'm tired my soul
she making us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
no no no no no no no
[Music]
[Music]